Let's see how we can use
underscore's templating capabilities
to add custom data to our app.
We will be going through
a lot of detail here, and
I highly suggest that you follow
along with your dev tools open,
navigating through
the source code yourself.
Digging into a framework source code
is the best way to really see how it
works under the hood.
As we're going through this,
don't get bogged down with all the code.
Focus on how the template gets
converted from HTML to a function.
That's right, a function.
A function that waits to
get called with data.
Here's the app we'll be using as
we work through this material.
And this is the HTML file for the app.
Let's look at how these
rows end up like this
when the template starts out like this.
There are a couple of things we need
to pay attention to with the template.
First is the ID here.
It will be used to select
the script tag, and its contents.
The second thing are these
characters here, and here.
These are called delimiters.
A delimiter is just a fancy name for
a sequence of one or
more characters used to form a boundary.
We need these delimiters
to separate the HTML
from what will become
JavaScript variables.
These delimiters are broken into
starting delimiters here, and
ending ones here.
The specific sequence of characters
is the default for underscore.
If I open underscore.js in a new pain,
we can see them here.
See how interpolate
has the angle bracket.
Percent sign.
And equal sign.
And the closing delimiters here.
This middle section captures
anything between the starting and
ending delimiters.
Evaluate, interpretulate, and escape
all have different starting delimiters.
We'll see why this is important and
how these will be used later.
So we have this template and it's
filled with these special delimiters.
But how does it get converted
to what's seen in the browser?
In app JS on this line,
the template is fetched from the DOM and
this HTML content is
returned as a string.
This string version of the template
is then passed into underscores
template function.
This template function is
where all the magic happens.
Let's take a sneak peek at what the
template function does by copying this
code and pasting it into the console.
We can look at the result
of the template function,
by checking the source property.
The template function
returns the function itself.
Functions are extremely powerful, and
the template function makes use of
a JavaScript constructor function.
Let's look at how
a constructor function works.